a estas horas las calles de santiago
vuelven a recuperar un poco la
normalidad después de que el tránsito
haya sido interrumpido en la mañana de
varios puntos de la alameda la avenida
que ven al fondo y que atraviesa una
gran parte de santiago esto por una
nueva manifestación de estudiantes
convocado por la organización mucha báez
en la que se ha convocado a unos 200 300
estudiantes que han atravesado la
alameda en varios puntos de la capital
para demandar una educación de calidad
gratuita no sexista y por ejemplo un
incremento en la beca de alimentación
que también sufre las consecuencias de
la ola inflacionaria que se vive en el
país y en el que el dinero que se
estableció hace unos años no rinde de la
misma forma como ahora alegan los
estudiantes ha habido incidentes
violentos como la quema de un bus
enfrentamientos como la policía con este
sería el tercer bus que se quema en esta
semana en distintas manifestaciones
también de institutos reconocidos y
prestigiosos en el país ante quejas de
en la situación en la que se encuentra
la infraestructura del sistema educativo
en chile una demanda por una educación
de calidad que se pone de manifiesto
que es ahora el presidente del país y
que fue en otro momento un líder
estudiantil y gabriel boy que se le pide
que atienda las necesidades urgentes del
sistema educativo en chile